lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
hablar de los errores tipo 1 y errores
tipo 2 esto en el contexto de las
pruebas de significancia a manera de
repaso para realizar una prueba de
significancia requerimos una hipótesis
nula y una hipótesis alternativa las
cuales establecemos para una población
en particular las hipótesis se
establecen en relación con algún
parámetro de esta población
la hipótesis nula contiene la
aseveración que se supone es real el
status quo mientras que la hipótesis
alternativa contempla la posibilidad de
que haya algún cambio en relación al
parámetro hay algo alternativo en ella
cuando las probamos en realidad estamos
probando la hipótesis nula vamos a
decidir si rechazamos o no rechazamos la
hipótesis nula lo que hacemos es tomar
una muestra a partir de la población
para la cual determinamos algún
estadístico con objeto de estimar el
parámetro de interés calculamos entonces
la probabilidad de obtener ese
estadístico con base a nuestra muestra
que tiene un tamaño específico bajo la
suposición de que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera si esta probabilidad la cual
se conoce como valor p es menor que un
cierto valor que hemos fijado
y manu conocido como el nivel de
significancia entonces rechazaremos la
hipótesis nula vamos a escribir esto
este de aquí es el valor p recuerden que
estamos haciendo un repaso esto ya lo
hemos visto en otros vídeos si el valor
p es menor que el nivel de significancia
entonces rechazamos la hipótesis nula y
si el valor p es mayor o igual que alfa
el nivel de significancia entonces no
rechazamos la hipótesis nula al rechazar
la hipótesis nula podemos sospechar la
validez de la hipótesis alternativa esto
tiene sentido pues si la probabilidad de
obtener un estadístico en una muestra
con un tamaño específico suponiendo que
la hipótesis nula es verdadera resulta
ser razonablemente pequeña menor que
cierto umbral digamos que el umbral es
de 5% si la probabilidad de que eso
ocurra es menor que 5% entonces es
razonable rechazar la hipótesis nula sin
embargo podríamos en uno u otro caso
tomar la decisión equivocada de ahí
surgen este tipo de errores
hagamos un cuadro sobre esto aquí
tenemos lo que ocurre en realidad dos
posibles situaciones la primera es que
la hipótesis nula es verdadera
la segunda es que la hipótesis nula es
falsa y con base a nuestra prueba de
significancia hay dos situaciones que
pueden darse podemos rechazar la
hipótesis nula o podemos no rechazar la
hipótesis nula hagamos entonces el
cuadro donde consideramos los diversos
casos en el caso en que la hipótesis
nula sea verdadera pero la rechazamos
estamos incurriendo en un error no
deberíamos rechazar algo que es
verdadero de hecho ese es el error del
tipo 1 no deberíamos de rechazar la
hipótesis nula si es verdadera más aún
podemos calcular la probabilidad de
obtener un error del tipo 1 esta va a
ser igual al nivel de significancia ya
que si la hipótesis nula es verdadera y
digamos que el nivel de significancia es
5% esto es que el 5% de las veces que va
a suceder que aunque la hipótesis nula
sea verdadera vamos a obtener un
estadístico que nos lleve a rechazarla
en suma la probabilidad del error de
tipo 1 es igual al nivel de
significancia ahora si la hipótesis nula
es verdadera y no la rechazamos esto
está bien estamos obteniendo una
conclusión correcta bien si la hipótesis
nula es falsa y la rechazamos también
esta también es una conclusión correcta
pero si la hipótesis nula es falsa y no
la rechazamos ese es un error del tipo 2
con esto en mente en los siguientes
vídeos haremos ejemplos en los que
trataremos de identificar si estamos
incurriendo en un error y si éste es del
tipo 1 o del tipo 2 nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo